-Our next guest
is an award-winning
and Michelin-starred chef.
You can catch him in L.A.
December 1st, 2nd, and 3rd
for ChainFest, the world's first
chain-food festival.
Please welcome chef
Tim Hollingsworth.
Hey!
-What's up, everybody?
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
-Time, nice to see you bud.
Welcome.
-Thank you, thank you.
-Tariq.
-Good to be here.
-Chef, can you explain
what ChainFest is?
What inspired it?
-I mean, we throw
massive, 300-person
dinner parties back in L.A.,
where we focus on making iconic
chain dishes in a gourmet way.
-Now, can you walk us
through some of these things?
Tell me about
these things tonight.
What is this one over here?
-This right here is the the
Chili's babyback rib-wich.
So we have a $3,000 bottle
of Pappy Van Winkle
that went into that
barbecue sauce as glazing.
We also have these Wagyu beef,
iconic Jack in the Box
tacos with the curly fries.
-Oh, my God.
-And we have sweet-and-sour
Pepsi sauce.
-You're elevating this.
You're upcycling these dishes.
-Upcycling.
[ Laughter ]
-That's not a --
It's not a popular term.
-I mean...
-Dunkin'.
All right.
So what are you doing
with Dunkin'?
-Dunkin' Donuts?
We have three different versions
of doughnuts here.
We have a creme brulee doughnut,
we have a bacon doughnut,
and we've taken
the iconic strawberry doughnut,
and we turned it
into a drink here.
So it's espresso and strawberry
with sprinkle on it doughnut.
-Cold brew?
-Yes.
-And then Red Robin.
What'd you do here?
-Last but not least,
yes, Red Robin.
We have -- They're famous
for their burgers, right?
So we have a burgertini
with a savory beef broth.
-Oh, wow.
-I mean...
-Yeah. Not bad.
I don't understand what I
just drank, but it's great.
[ Laughter ]
-Wow.
-That's actually not --
I love that.
That's not bad.
I figured that, tonight,
in honor of ChainFest,
we'd do something fun.
It's time for "The Tonight Show
Chain Challenge."
-Oh, yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ Tonight Show ♪
-♪ Tonight Show
Chain Challenge ♪
♪ Yeah, yeah ♪
-All right,
here's how this works.
Tariq and I will have 45 seconds
to create our own
original menu items
using existing
chain-restaurant foods.
We can use as many
chain-restaurant items
as we want, but we must
transform the dish
into something new.
We also have access
to the pantry.
Chef Tim will take a bite
of each finished dish
and determine the winner,
who will receive
"The Tonight Show"
Chain Championship Chain.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Chain chain!
Put 45 seconds on the clock.
On your mark,
get set, go!
All right, here we go.
Coming over.
All right.
Here's what I'm doing.
I'm gonna make
a Korean-style chicken sandwich.
I'm putting nuggets in here.
Right?
Putting some gochujang, some
spicy Korean paste in there.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-That's good.
Tariq, what do you got?
-I got a little chicken.
I got a little...
-I got to put a little...
-...doughnut action there.
-A little soy sauce.
-Chicken doughnut.
-Soy sauce in there.
-The inspiration is --
-Soy sauce in there!
I'm putting a little --
little sesame oil in there.
-He's making chicken and waffle.
-A little sesame oil in there!
-Got chicken and waffles!
-I'm putting, uh, honey.
I'm putting honey in there.
I can't open this.
Oh, yeah.
A little rice vinegar.
Honey in there.
-Look at that, look at that.
-How much time?
[ Ding! ]
-Pickles, chicken.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-All right, here we go.
[ Laughter ]
-All right. Tariq, knives down!
Tariq, don't --
No more.
Tariq, knives down, bud.
Nice try.
There you go. Hands up!
All right, here we go.
Time is up.
Chef Tim.
What I made for you tonight,
using Red Robin ingredients,
is a Korean-styled chicken
nugget chicken sandwich
with gochujang.
Some sesame oil in there.
You got some rice vinegar.
You want a little honey
in there,
you get a little pickle taste
on that Red Robin bun.
Look at this.
Wow. You should see --
Wow. Yeah.
Well, you can't complain
about that, right?
Come on. Yeah, respect.
That's what I'm talking about.
-Sweet, sour, spicy.
-I like the pickles.
You took the breading off.
-Yeah, I took the --
Yeah, I took -- yeah.
Thank you.
Appreciate that.
-So, in honor of the release
of my book, "The Upcycled Self,"
I've upcycled this chain food.
And I took, you know,
two glazed doughnuts,
and I made
that my sandwich base.
And I did something that's like
a spin on the classic
chicken and waffles.
I used, you know,
the Chili's boneless wings.
I added a little sriracha,
a little honey,
and a little pickle
to top it off.
-Sounds like what I made
a little bit.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, wow.
-And I also like you a lot, man.
Like, I think -- I think
you're a pretty cool, dude.
-Thank you.
Thank you.
I appreciate it.
-It's been great having you.
-I appreciate it, yeah.
I mean, you --
you eat too much of that,
you're gonna upcycle
in the morning.
You know what I'm saying?
[ Laughter ]
Chef, there can only be
one winn--
There can only be one winner.
Who gets "The Tonight Show"
Chain Chain?
-The winner of "Tonight Show"
Chain Challenge,
and the recipient
of "The Tonight Show"
Chain Championship Chain is...
...Tariq.
-Wow!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh-whee!
-Come on, now.
-It looks good on him.
Look at that.
-Chef Tim Hollingsworth.
-Check out ChainFest in L.A.
December 1st through the 3rd.
We'll be right back.
More "Tonight Show."
Stick around, everybody.